[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mes chers compatriotes chacun d'entre
nous ressent au quotidien que la vie est
de plus en plus cher le travail de plus
en plus rares l'insécurité de plus en
plus forte et que le communautarisme
menace l'unité de la république depuis
vingt ans les partis politiques au
pouvoir démantèle de protection à succès
nos entreprises abandonnent la
transmission des repères et valeurs de
la société
c'est ainsi que notre pays a perdu peu à
peu la maîtrise de son territoire de ses
lois et de ses libertés
au point que les français ne croient
plus en la politique n'est en l'avenir
mais demain avec le patriotisme
je veux rendre l'espoir aux français
identité nationale marseillaise drapeau
tricolore maîtrise de l'immigration
protection européenne
tout au long de cette campagne les
candidats sont venus se positionner les
uns après les autres sur les thèmes que
philippe de villiers défend depuis tant
d'années à l'heure de faire votre choix
ce ne sont pas les paroles et les
promesses qui compte mais la certitude
que celui pour lequel nous allons voter
respectera ses engagements
comme beaucoup d'entre vous en 2002 j'ai
cru que la majorité élue dont je faisais
partie allait mettre tous ses pouvoirs
pour aller au bout des réformes dont
notre pays a besoin
député à l'assemblée nationale j'ai
défendu avec conviction une vraie
politique de droite
malheureusement je me suis bien vite
senti seul j'ai par exemple essayer de
mettre fin au droit exorbitant accordé
aux clandestins comme l'aide médicale
d'état ce milliard d'euros que nous
dépensons chaque année pour les frais de
santé des étrangers en situation
irrégulière quand les français comme les
étrangers en situation régulière doivent
payer le ticket modérateur ce droit
injuste bénéficie à 200 mille
clandestins
malheureusement et malgré les
engagements de la campagne
je n'ai pas été suivi je pensais aussi
que nous avons le droit de dire que
l'islam doit s'adapter à la république
et non pas la république à l'islam mais
lorsque nicolas sarkozy a annoncé la
création du conseil français du culte
musulman
j'ai compris que la logique
communautariste l'avait emporté comme
beaucoup d'entre vous je me suis encore
senti trahi
quand j'ai vu ma famille politique
renoncer à abolir les 35 heures défendre
la discrimination positive plutôt que le
mérite
le mariage homosexuel plutôt que la
famille cette fois ci comme vous je ne
veux pas de déception
comment croire ce qu'ils promettent pour
demain ce qu'ils n'ont pas pu ou pas su
faire quand ils avaient le pouvoir
devant tant de contradictions on
recherchait ligne droite cette ligne
c'est philippe de villiers qui
l'incarnent
ces réussites locales la cohérence de
ses idées auxquelles il est toujours
resté fidèle son projet offensif pour
que nous retrouvions ensemble la fierté
d'être français prouve sa sincérité et
sa capacité à agir
votez philippe de villiers c'est la
garantie d'une droite qui le pire a mis
devant la gauche ni devant la rue
aujourd'hui le vrai vote utile pour la
droite c'est le choix de la droite
patriotique de gouvernement c'est le
choix de philippe de villiers en tant
que président du conseil général de la
vendée
j'ai agi à contre-courant les politiques
menées au niveau national j'ai fait de
la vendée une terre de réussite
les résultats sont là au classement de
tous les palmarès la vendée fait la
course en tête
fort de cette réussite est convaincu que
les grandes choses se font avec le coeur
je me présente à vous comme l'homme du
patriotisme
parce que le patriotisme apparaît comme
la seule réponse face aux problèmes
majeurs de notre pays qui doit
impérativement retrouver la maîtrise de
son avenir
je ne suis pas un politicien
contrairement à tant d'autres
par tempérament et par expérience je
suis un créateur un entrepreneur un
bâtisseur je vous propose d'élargir
demain
l'expérience de la réussite vendéenne à
l'échelle de toute la france
pour moi le pouvoir n'est pas un bien de
consommation
c'est un service le service des français
et de la france que j'aime c'est
pourquoi fort de la cohérence de mes
convictions je sollicite votre confiance
[Musique]